foreign
Salt Lake City Utah hi Nick how are you
good how are you too better than we
deserve how can we help
Cricket
um I'll try to make this brief I'm
trying to figure out if I should leave
my toxic work environment yes and go yes
my old
okay
tell us about yourself what's toxic
about it
so
um a little backstory I had to come here
to get benefits from because my previous
Place didn't have any benefits and so
we
my family had a major crisis in our
lives where
my wife tried to
sorry
particular life
sorry okay so you had to take this job
for the for the insurance so she could
get the care that she needed
correct yeah because we couldn't she had
to go
when she wasn't a kid she was
recommended to go to a psychiatrist a
therapist I'm sorry
um for
a minimum of two times a week and we got
it down to one time a week but paying
out of pocket was just going to be where
we would have been homeless and we have
a one-year-old or we'd love to be one
and we just didn't see a solution board
and we how long how long ago was that
in 2020 last year it was around November
so a little over a year ago
hey can I just stop you right here and
applaud you for being a husband who
loves his wife enough to do whatever it
takes
thank you it's you're an impressive
Brave man and I'm proud to get to share
a conversation with you man you quit a
job that you liked in order to take a
job that you had to take so that you
could care for your family and that's
what people do in hard times and I'm
proud of you
thank you so it sounds like the memory
job provides medical benefits but also
pretty awful too
yeah so I I took it because it was a
higher paying job and when we got the
medical bill it was
very high where we're obviously in debt
right now and so
that was the main reason was for the
benefits to pay for therapy as well as
be able to pay for the medical bill just
to get out of it and what do you mean
about a Year's worth of salary
um at this new place that make it up for
me 78th doing what at the old place
um engineering you're an engineer
yes
yes okay
and how old are you
I am 20 about the 28th so you've been
licensed three years four years
no no so I just started working about
two and a half years ago so we we didn't
know about you guys until you know I'm
asking how long you've been an engineer
oh yeah for about two and a half years
only okay all right and what's the
problem at the new place what's the
Define what toxic means in this case
so anytime I get yelled at on a weekly
basis and there's been times where I've
been yelled at in front of my colleagues
and have been threatened that if I don't
get get it right then I'm going to be
out of here the next day okay let me
stop you saying okay are you being
confronted
about performance or are you being
yelled at with actual volume
you get out there with actual volume
okay
or yeah here's this is a I'm going to
ask this directly and kind of I mean
it's hard
is this you being like it's hurting my
feelings or is this no dude this dude's
like getting all up in my face like if
we were outside there'd be a problem
kind of kind of yelling at you
yeah if we were outside there'll be
appalled and that's and that's where I'm
not sure what to do because I can handle
it then I can take it but it's to the
point where it's just becoming I would
think there'll be a lot of engineering
jobs in Salt Lake City that included
medical benefits
have you looked yet
yeah I've looked at a couple of
different areas and tried to apply to a
few different places and a lot of them
are hiring and I've had a couple
interviews with them however there's
just we're in a small town where
if I were to go there it's about a 45
minute commute to an hour commute for me
to get to the other places that I'm
interested in I can't do that more than
I can be yelled at because my yelling
button is fairly low mine too
like one time
um I also can consider
um moving communities if I have to move
a little bit closer to where I work we
all locked into this community that
you're a part of right now
yeah so we have a house we bought it a
couple years ago and so we have we do
have a house and the reason we're living
where we are right now is because we
have parents that are close by that can
watch a little boy especially right now
since she's working part-time so we can
try to pay off this debt they're going
to therapy it's
we're just both trying to pay it off as
fast as we can sure
I don't want you to lose your
relationship or your sanity in the
process okay
okay yeah you gotta you gotta you gotta
have to do something else and we just
got to find out what and it may be it
maybe pick your poison uh I'm picking
I'll make a commute before I get yelled
at
I'm picking I'm going to keep looking
and looking and looking and find
something very soon because it's not
going to be long for I tell this guy to
take this job and shove it
yeah like I mean like 30 seconds so I'm
I because I'm a redneck it's hard for me
to put up with that stuff I'm
I mean I get all hillbilly on you that
ain't gonna work I don't do yelling you
know and you're just thinking about you
experiencing that can you imagine
we actually had a team member a while
back a few years ago yell at one of our
leaders here and he fired him on the
spot and it's like he goes why are you
firing me was like because we like our
civilized human beings in here you you
know you're done you belligerent little
twerp and say oh my God yeah man your
instincts and your guts are right I'm
with Dave I would rather come home with
Integrity 30 minutes later every day and
what I mean by Integrity not brow
beating down and not exhausted and not
hating my life but I do think that you
know don't put too many constraints on
this there's no way to do this except in
this other bad way right there's you
know sometimes if the only options I've
got are two bad ones that means I don't
have enough options right and so I want
you to go keep looking and poking and
looking and poking and looking and
poking and find you something or open up
your own engineering thing on the side
and drive Uber at night I don't know but
um you know let's do something different
very very quickly
like I don't like the end of January you
have a new job Nick that's what I'm
prescribing I'm telling you to go do
that
okay perfect does that make sense
and yeah you know I don't care it might
be that you buy your own health
insurance and you get paid 100 at the
other place
instead of 70. okay that makes sense
I'll do that one too I mean I don't you
know benefits are good but they're not
worth 60 000 bucks a year so I mean if
you can make more money someplace else
and you don't have a commute and you got
to buy your own health insurance have at
it that's right but your dignity doesn't
have a price tag brother yeah and just
you you know well I mean it's dignity
it's also just
Humanity it's just you know we're just
not gonna act like these what are you
who yells in the and I mean it's not
like this is a
a ditch digging firm or something I mean
this is an engineer's who thinks they
can get I mean here's the thing they can
get away with it high paid white-collar
jobs somebody who's gotten away with it
yeah nobody ever hires brand new newly
uh certified engineers and just and
overpays them so he can abuse them or
possibly underpays them and runs them
into the ground and gets what he wants
they leave and he has his bad attitude
and starts it over again where are you
going don't have any payments not here
that's right that's right
that's somewhere else not here not today
you are confused individual
oh man but hey uh Kudos man for for
doing the hard thing and yeah quitting a
job stud Nick loving your words throw
your shoulders back step into the next
thing because you're good at stepping
into the next thing you've done a good
job with it and uh
yeah
yeah that place is not deserving of
someone with as much character as you
have sir